I thought watchers I'm gonna suck you dick
maybe maybe I will
I really hope my audio wasn't messed up to
much um that goldfoot club I didn't see
anyone complaining so I was like oh
sure enough
Alarieflings good morning good evening
good afternoon there's a frog blink
there I saw that I frog blinked I saw
that
I don't see that MSP
okay no I know it says doodling my gen
I didn't want Azura to know what I'm
actually doing okay secret stream no
snitch and all that exactly the booty
lord
I didn't want Azura to know what
shaggagans were up to
um so if you didn't know it's uh Azura's
doing a song and it's her birthday
because it was national gold day
um her funds are to move out and you
already know the drill you can literally
her link is in the description below
we will keep this a secret moment don't
thank you will this
poon will this poon
for the extended membership will this
poon
I'm definitely not saying that right
okay so I have zero xp and my xp bar
for drawing so what we have to do in
order to get it to work right is
um show a picture which
uh yep that's not correct where the
fuck did the picture go
sorry I'm dumb
so I made oh no it's really big
um I don't know why it's really big
please relax uh so the problem is I
can't draw and that's okay I can
admit it it's not a big deal that I
can't draw so I had to make a reference
okay and a reference is really normal
to use but the problem is the reference
had to be me so you're getting a white
women jump scare okay you're getting a
white women jump scare but the artwork
that we're drawing is a zero as a giant
test
that's the artwork
I used myself as a reference so we're
drawing a zero as a giant test and this
is not going to come out ever once it's
to go but it's fine it's fine so I had
to basically set up my camera so it was
on the floor so I was like doing a step
in motion on it and then I had to set it
up so I was like oh no don't crush me oh
no so there you go that's that's totally
not me to use as a reference I'm just
gonna pull it up on my other screen as
well so I can look at it
I don't know how this is gonna go
don't don't think this is gonna be mlg pro
it's gonna be nothing okay it's not
gonna be like oh my god you're so talented
starting no it's not
um so when it comes to doing art why
does azure azure seem scared to step on
you no she's not scared to step on me
and azure is almost like thank you holy
shit she's hiring that truck I was I was
kidding being like oh you know she's
gonna hire the truck uh today no uh I
don't think I'm kidding anymore and I
don't think that's happening right so
that's her like oh my god this is
terrible wait no how about how about
let's start really basic heads
heads shoulders knees and toes knees oh
my god this is not gonna go how I want
it to go because he's like chiseler or
john shit this is not gonna go how I
want it to go it's fine it's fine look
it's for fun okay and then her boobs are
actually like pov and because she would
have them oh my god this is not gonna
walk
fuck right this is not tracing would be
so much easier should I just straight up
but if I I can't trace it because it's
gonna be like how do I send it to her
because this is ms paint doesn't have
layers unless you want me to raw dog
trace it from obs potentially yes hold
on wait hold on this is not gonna work
how I want it to work but we're gonna do
it anyway I am good no this isn't gonna
work that's like oh my god this might
work wait maybe I can do the stencil of
her like a hand when you do a turkey
oh my god hold on right I'm just gonna
do I'm just gonna do the outside okay
I'm just gonna do the outside now either
this will work or this will be the worst
idea we've done so far I'm just doing the
outside I just want to do the outside of
the hand
okay and then we'll do the anime fingers
where they're like together but not okay
hold on ms paint has layers now shut up
the world's dumbest hackathon would it be
funnier if it was really scuffed though
wouldn't that be what everyone wants to
see
oh right down the leg and then go over
here that's my leg
oh my god
hmm
should I just shade myself is there a
skin color and send it to her
is this isn't gonna oh wait no that's what
they call black faces or something like
that okay right no we're not doing that
hold on right I need to figure out how
ms paint has layers let's do new no I
don't want to save right layers is this
old ms paint or is this new ms paint
view fullscreen thumbnail 100%
zoom out zoom in fullscreen now home
where's the layer strong 8 will this
reference will be available for public
use
no I'll get like a proper artwork msp
back so you're gay or as I thought
never I always got their masterpiece first
try so you're pretty much on your way
there
should I just go for it I think that's
what the charm of it would be is that
it's like yeah it's scuffed but it's me
I made it with love a hand drawing is
much more personal do it you can do it
okay I'm just gonna go for it so head
first
and then her horns I didn't realize how
much her horns and then don't worry
we'll go like over the other details
type thing that's not very symmetrical
is it
and then her wee ears would come out
and before anyone's like what do you mean
her ears yes those are her goat ears
for she is a goat got it
and that's really beautiful pin it on the
fridge thank you dad I appreciate that
uh right and then in the reference my
boobs are like coming up so wouldn't
as there's tits literally be like this
in the fucking shot how do you do
perspective
I have an idea I've got an eagle I'm just
going for it wing it and then she'd
have a big fucking massive knockers
right oh this is not gonna work
I don't know how perspective work and
before anyone asked no I can't rotate
an apple in my head I can't do anything
in my head it doesn't work like that
right fucking shoulder would be here
and then it would come down and then it
would come over
oh my god
I was gonna send her this and talk to her
on stream after I was done oh my god
oh my god
oh my god if they're just hit 10k
well she's gonna think this is an insult
but did she actually that's fantastic
holy sheiko no way
can I feed you holy fuck the bleeding
heart said move the fuck out we want
that ASMR
oh my god
okay
who knew art could be so hard like
actually right she's got massive jibbly
okay so one jibbly-bibbly here and a
second jibbly-bibbly here and then she's
got fried eggs the way my dad describes
it and then it's like a strap all the way
up the worst part is there's an
artist she's gonna you recognize how
like scuff this is i'm sorry is there
i didn't mean to i've tried my best do
that do that and then it goes up onto
her shoulder strap right and then it's
like gold plated so it would have to
have like this extra bit here right and
then her ears have a little gold plate
on them because she's she's majestic
i'm so crazy okay and then
she'd have one i don't know how to draw
perspective like that i genuinely don't
fuck it let's just draw the foot
let's just draw the foot first okay so
that's my toe and that's my other toe
then that's a third toe this is another
one so ma wee pinky toe like it's stuck
to my ring toe does that make sense
it's not stuck like i can move it but i
would have to like flex it to move it
and then one more right and then the
foot the way the foot works it kind of
comes out but then it goes in to get
skinny and then it goes out and then gets
big again oh no it doesn't sugar it
doesn't work like that hold on go back
hold on reverse it right so the foot does
go around but at the toe it goes like out
and then it goes in oh my god hold on a
minute we might be able to save this if
we use the foot to cover up half of her
body
we might be able to save this we might be
able to save this okay and then we need
her her like leg slash knee
and then
oh no i do this sounds like they will
it shouldn't oh see if her leg was like
that i would have to like cut up like that
and you see her fanny
from my perspective i think i would have
to move her foot over her jibblies
or would it be funnier if i left the
anatomy absolutely terrible because i
don't know how to do the anatomy
ooh that might be funnier
if the anatomy is scuffed i think it
makes it even funnier
so in theory if her leg had to come up
it her crotch would be visible so that's
like her butt cheek yeah it would be like
her butt cheek and then up and but then
what does she wear on her abdomen again
you think i was me they're designer no
honestly i was there for the fucking
design right hold on let me just pop up
her
honestly you think i was me sitting being
like that's a good design and that uh
sure yeah uh was in the design process for
gen one
come on show us your crotch show us your
crotch that's terrible
wait why can't i see her no she must have a
reference sheet pinned she doesn't pin her
reference sheet she pins her schedules
oh right fine i'm taping in azura ref
surely she put on twitter like that
azura duly ref i swear if this doesn't
come up i give up i'm gonna have to go to
google i'm having to google my child
azura duly reference surely she tweeted
out at one point i'm going on the vtuber
wikipedia oh my god that's her pale ass
model that was before she got her upgrade
she's so pale no where's the ret where's
the rest of you oh she has a suit
yeah that's right so the suit would like go
up her belly and her fanny and she has
like a nice little belly so she'd have
like a little oh no that looks like a
no and then what oh my god
how am i insulting her i don't know how i'm
doing that and then what her leg would be
like all the way down
it looks like she's got a package
right
right this is her suit okay i think once
we color it in hold on let me color it
in i'm sure she will zero i love it
when you send it sir i'm practicing for
john for isy because she said my doodle
for her return after week uh break had her
a lot of rest assured it's the felt that
counts her i literally is like that's
supposed to be right if that's supposed
to be our butt cheek hold on let's
let's get right into the news okay if
that's supposed to be a butt cheek in
theory it would actually come out like
at the back of here that looks even
worse how do female bodies work ken
what i've had enough of you and let's
just do a line fuck it no right no
extend this is how clothes works extend
the suit yes okay hold on a minute next
we need to put a kneecap in gorgeous
stunning next if we're lucky maybe a bit
definition on the toes you know the
toe ridges so if you didn't know toes
i like have a little fold and i'm like
we'll just do a tiny little one there
okay we're getting somewhere now don't
write me out just yet we're getting
somewhere now um does she have wrinkly
like you know how like those feet that
have like the nice wrinkles come okay
we're not gonna do that we're getting
somewhere okay for her other arm needs
to be apparent okay mm-hmm
all right and then she does have hip
straps uh i guess we're just gonna give
them up at some point and then i guess
you wouldn't technically see your hip
straps from here so that's fine and then
on her legies she has this thigh highs
with stirrup socks oh no her foot would be
covered because she has stirrup socks
oh my god oh no her toes are out oh my god
saved her toes are out thank goodness her
designed like this her toes are out and
she has stirrup the design is saved god
i want mommy to draw me like a to draw
you like a french girl
guru guru guru you're next thank god
right exposed toes and she has stirrup
so the back is also exposed we are
actually saved so she does have two
ankle it's um on her thighs as well so
we're just gonna put that detail in
there right i'll try and fix up the arm
because let's be honest that's atrocious
um okay okay we can work with this this
is a base is it based on red pelt i don't
know next we need to draw
uh someone getting smush so basically i'm
just gonna go for the white outline of
a guy so anyone can like i think they
say it's called your name it's like your
name oh it's like yin oh i have a cup of
tea i forgot sorry let me drink my tea
and i'm gonna i'm gonna forget
thank you bob for the super chat i will draw
guru like a french girl sitting outside
right basically we just want a like a
white outline of a guy and he's got his
hands up and he's like stop please don't
hurt me
but his fingers are spread to show how
scared he is of our giant test
oh honestly it looks like he's he's like oh
thank you for putting me at my misery i
no longer have to pay taxes
thank you
uh honestly yeah that's not bad okay and
we're gonna move them a bit closer to
so the implication is ah please don't hurt me
is there a
splat
cartoon fatal maybe we can put in some
dialogue to make it an anime oh wait no
we might need to make them a bit can we
get much higher so right okay i'm not
mad at this base so what we're going to
do we're going to fix this hand because
i'm taking the pis s with that okay so
first let's fix the hand and then we'll
fix to the head area okay so let's get
rid of the shoulder being like that uh
she can keep her fried eggs that's fine
i think
her her arm would come down like this to
like stabilize herself maybe
let's let's see so no that's like a
sausage don't draw is there a sausage
okay one two three and then maybe she's
like kind of holding her head oh yes
that's very logical yeah okay maybe not
so big on that part okay not so big on
that part and then give it like a little
detail like a little bump to do a line
there it kind of shows that the the arm
is like coming out to make sense
okay do it given to the bootlegation
no she's not got a boot up it's got a big booty
you can see a booty big booty big booty
okay so yeah that's even better and then
this one it implies maybe she's like
holding her thigh from the top so you
can't see it right we definitely need
to fix the face though because that is
that's rough that's rough
right so let's remove the head
because we're gonna put the anime face
on her so that so as there is like okay
that already to me looks better i don't
know maybe i'm just going to get sprenic
because i'm like oh my god anything to do
is better than the original thing so she
got a very symmetrical face but you wouldn't
know unless you really looked her she has
a lot of hair that actually covers like
so much detail on her face but it's no
problem like it's just her design type
thing
and right eyes are always like halfway
down so her eyes should start like y'all
uh like anime at me give me oh no wait no
you're a goat
why is she like so feral
oh i just realized the reference is in the
way
maybe i move that over just a little bit
but she's like oh i'm about to kill you
oh
that's supposed to be the sound effect i
tried i tried
yeah i cannot for the life of me joe anime
eyes i don't know how this works oh
wait no is there eyes aren't open like
that what my day in is there has really
eyes she gives she gives a good suck with
eyes like that i said what said i don't
care right so she has eyebrows that are
nice and cute and tell our kawaii
desune oh hold on you know what there
that'll do okay so azura has like pure
fucking sexy eyes she's got like uh i'm
gonna fuck you and and you're gonna
remind you're gonna remember in three
years time and you're still gonna be
thinking about me you're gonna be
fucking your girlfriend and you're gonna
think about me baby that's what azura's
eyes are okay and then she's got her
little goat part nope along down and
then we're going to do the cheater
thing it's not a cheater thing all
artists do this you take the eye and
then you flip it oh yeah mm-hmm this
looks uncanny valley but i'll take it
and then oh don't whatever that was
don't do that again i almost shot my
panty loons losing all that progress
there and then we'll fix this bit but
mobile we're doing it why is there a
foot on the screen i'm the reference
we're drawing giant tess azura but i had
to use myself as a reference look tell
me we're not doing a good job look at
the comparison
come on
come on tell me that's not good i think
that's amazing the speech bubble has to
be please step on me mommy
yes the speech bubble has to say yes
please step on me mommy let's do that
and then we'll rotate it
okay we'll move we'll move them along
a bit once i'm finished making her
face a bit better
and one talented girl why did you have
to draw the feet she's a giant tess
come on giant tess is all about the feet
it's all about getting panzeried it's
all about just going cave diving you
know
are being squished
uh i'll make an indication that she's
like a billion centimeters tall as well
right okay her hair is kind of like it
goes quite big like here as well too
um but she also has like a front pump
like this and then she has her jewelry
but it also like comes over her face
and outwards in this direction as well
and over her horns like she's got a really
good fucking design sorry i'm biased but
i love my daughters i'm so fucking biased
i don't care what anyone's like i'm so
biased right actually we're gonna have to
extend the side bit a bit more to kind of
cover up the attachment of the ears to her
head i think if people realized how the
goat's ears were attached to her head
they'd be like oh but it's like she
doesn't have human ears she's a more
fucking goat right and then her hair
gets big it comes out as well like a
little bit and then a big bit and then a
wee bit again and then a wee bit and then
a wee bit a big bit a wee bit and then a
wee bit again and then her hair actually
a lot of people don't know this her hair
extends all the way down past her butt
and but you don't get to see it too much
just because obviously you'll never guess
what her feature remodels are all
uh you know because that's how long it is
but yeah she got super long hair super long
okay we'll start coloring in yeah right
i'm happy with that if you are we'll do
like the classic like anime shading
under the chin i think i think you know
for yeah it needs some you know it needs
improvement and stuff but you know what
i'm not even mad at that okay i'm not even
mad at that let me get let me take out the
sagoy disney death and then we'll put in
the sentence thank you crazy jesse for
that suggestion i'm literally gonna do
that right now i'm gonna move her over
i'm gonna move both of them over because
they're both in this mess together
okay they're both in this mess together
right and then
so you two come over yep we're going to do
a speech bubble we're gonna tell it to do
a backflip and then it's going to say
oh what am i doing uh it's going to say
yes please comma step on me mummy right
and then we're going to make sure it's an
anime please tell me i have anime i have
fucking lord of the rings but i don't have
the anime text are you serious how do i
have lord of the rings and not the anime
text oh come on of course i have
i'm looking oh my god i'm looking i have
lord of the rings but not fucking the
default anime text i'm not even downloading
it because my fucking pc will break itself
are you serious oh can i give it like an
interesting right there that's mildly
interesting where's the comma oh there's
just no comma in this one bro i'm not
giving her i'm not giving her
uh comic sans before anyone asks
aerial black maybe yeah sure that looks
official enough do you have a comma thank
you okay and then make it a bit smaller
make it a bit smaller there we go and
then we need to artificially center it
because oh and i fucked it up is the scuff
better if it's fucked up like this
should i just leave it like that yeah and
like purposely a little off to the right
by accident
it might as well use impact always impact
the mean font actually you might be right
hold on you may be right right yeah um
yes please call my step on me
oh call any sweet yes please step on me
mommy
i'm still like that and then impact impact
uh
okay that's good that's good now we
color her in okay how what colors are
here it's like a mix of these two
no it's still blue i don't care why
anyone says it's still blue or should
i purposely color in later you know when
the artists make something look really
good it's because they like purposely
make it later sniff the feet honestly
right i'll put away me right off you go
we don't need you anymore it was nice
a little acid a right she has purple
what's the purple on her feet as well
can't be strong either spelling wait what
yes please step on my mommy offer fucks
wait can i get away with this no can i get
away with that no no in freaking neon
step can we do it right we're doing a
surgery
oh he's gonna flat line there you would
never know i made a mistake pixel
motherfucking hair fact you're welcome
perfect right two fried eggs let's go
yellow with a bat and a boom oh shit her
design isn't like that at all all right
hold on hold on hold on right two fried
eggs getting redone uh there's a purple
look let's just start we're getting there
that's the main thing okay so she goes
like this so it goes yellow it goes
yellow and it goes yellow on the no
draft this is what i was worried about
because i've not closed off anything
should i go back okay you know what i
think i'm gonna have to go back and close
like everything stop
the patient is saved good work doctor
strongy would you trust me to operate on
you real answer right boobs that's fine
good drug will be in color eyes i might
have to do manually here i'm gonna try and
fill out the here horns seem to be to
themselves
implication lines on the horns
implication lines on the horns gotta go
maybe a bit black but that looks closed
off closed off closed off hair closed
yep and we're just gonna ms bucket this
absolute shagging this right that's closed
off closed around the hair the neck oh
the face needs to be closed off here
hands on the hips closed off here no not
closed off we're getting there maybe you
should try your luck and follow the
what does that mean what did i say
right i need to finish off close close close
right the bottom of her leg doesn't count
it's not going to be in frame
foot closed off happy that's closed off
so i'm gonna color in i'll be fine toes
toe check checking for toes toes are
closed off goods leg goods arm no goods
all right i dare we say i think it's time
to start coloring in this beauty and
before funk
ah i found it okay i found it literally
just turned her into an alien i made her
believe herself no not that one boom
boom no boom okay good no no
oh we're getting there no layers you're
feeling brave look some artists are born
like the oh no no wrong color boop
okay boop no over again there though
like we're gonna gather very quickly boop
no well yes but no boop boop okay okay
now what's wrong with you and particular
there's something wrong with you someone's
open is it you be honest no wrong color
use black
oh i'm getting trolled right now by ms paint
how about now yes okay tell him how you're
really feeling okay and then we need gold
on her ears yes oh my god as there is
coming to life i don't want to jinx it
there's her mouth okay close enough we need
to close her mouth off sorry that was me
having oversight okay uh i'm pretty sure
when you draw anime modes you have to like
go a bit lighter and then purposely do a
bit darker at the back of the mouth
let's do that we're like artists out here
okay we aren't half ass and this shit
okay no not like that how about we zoom in
to really get this pixel perfect and then
the back of the mouth has like shade to it
see see okay and then as there's eyebrows
are a dark brown but not that dark hold on
me me me and a boom all right and then
her skin tone is much lighter
it's actually got a bit more vibrant color
in terms of orange in the skin tone
you accidentally colored the left ear how
did i miss that i don't know how i missed
that's not quite right hold on let me
fix her ear i didn't realize i messed up
that badly
right let's make her wait no that's not
what i said that's not what i said and
then fix that bit on the ear
actually we're just gonna manually take
away this line by doing that okay and
then skin tone is like a orange kind of
cute it's more orange and then go lighter
i mean
i mean honestly
it is kind of the classic like anime tan
okay boom no close enough
oh my god look i don't want to say
anything but like i'm and i'm so down to
draw more majin mates on ms paint this is
so fun like when it finally comes
together i was so embarrassed but i'm
like i don't this is good sorry for
someone who's never drawn before this is
fucking good is it too late garu tan
is it too late
i've heard of green thumbs but green are
green ears are a bit too far from me
honestly it looks good you stuff i'm
just like blushing right so her hair is
behind here right her eye color is like
got definitely got an orange much orange
or cute so let's kind of bring this up a
bit okay and then we'll just ms paint
in her eyeballs there you go okay her
horns are like a dark kind of a purple
hue black i would say a purple hue
black
yeah uh it's definitely got purple in
there maybe be a bit less saturated
maybe like a hundred saturation on that
uh yeah yeah yeah down the eyelash and
eyelash i just joined this is beautiful
thank you uh we're getting
nope that's her outfit in between this
is her skin and then we just need her
fingers to be colored in nope her fingers
to be colored in nope her face
motherfucker you know exactly what i'm
selecting me right now
eating great moment thank you honestly
i've been so down to draw the girls like
this as well and ms paint doesn't have to
be good like i think when it comes to
this stuff like it is important just to
put your love into it and hopefully when
azure sees it i'm going to see if i can
jump in voice so what i'll do is when i
finish this i'll message azure and see
she's like available because i know she
has stuff planned and obviously i don't
want to like fucking steamroll to show
her and ms paint drawing like we're
really busy
um okay and then we've got purple
which we really zoomed out there right
and then we've got her purple
start wearing purple for me
that's a bit neon on that it's a bit neon
can we just tone it down a bit yeah
tone it down a bit yeah okay have a
that okay that's fair and that's a bit
less nope that's her ears stop it
leave her ears alone okay right one
detail i'm missing is the side of her
suit has gold all the way down it
i mean look all i'm saying is we're doing it
and then it goes like holy
i fucked up that one hold on let me go
again
thank you
uh crazy jesse for the compliments
compliments to the chef the chef why is it
are you squiddin me right now
toe ring on second toe oh real and true
real and true are you squiddin me right
now i will do it right now i don't think
i want oh hold on it needs to be free
it needs to be pixel perfect thank you
math for the extended membership and
thank you gun great for the membership
i appreciate it i hope you enjoy right
toe ring we're just going straight for it
i don't think there's anything in
particular that needs done for a toe
ring in my humble opinion not that i
know
let's see let's have a little zoom out oh
oh not bad oh we're missing something
here it looks like a skin tone i would
say that skin hold on hold on zoom in
so analize right you get filled in you
get filled in right now what we need to
do is do the shading what's drawing you
gonna do shading yes i'm going to do
shading what the fuck i said erase
why did you do that i don't know i'm
sure whatever uh right fill in that and
then to do shading literally just take
the color and then just do it a little
bit down that's it that's all you have to
do if you want and then we'll do the
we have to do it like pixel perfect though
because there's always shading like under
the neck and stuff and then we need to
shade her big mobility jubilee as well
mmm i bet you want to be that pixel
right there don't yeah you dirty i i
bet you do yeah i think i confused the
girls in my scots today i felt a bit
bad i was like that was having fun though
like that was such a hit in a hauler i
love when we get together
oh i missed i took out oh i took out another
pixel hold on i don't want to take it too
many pixels okay let's just shade this in
okay shaded that'll do and then like
we'll kind of take it here and then this
the light will get up no i guess the light
sources i don't know where the light
sources okay i don't know what we'll just
we'll just pretend the light source is
coming from over here okay so light
sources here so that means we have to
like put so much detail in her feet and
stuff okay boom and then like we would
shade like in between her toes and shit
no i mean yes but no
oh no having to shade in between the
toes how diabolical right let's really
get let's get in on them grippers okay
there we go we're like pixel perfect on
these grippers right now right so
everyone would technically have like a
little bit here okay if the source is
from over there oh no it'll be shadowed
really because she's about to stomp on
you like don't think into too much so
because this band is here it technically
would start at the band and then
then agree like come and agree over here
you know for someone who doesn't draw i
sure do come out with a lot of stuff off
the top of my head about it
like i'm pretty sure this is not how
shading works but i'm gonna do it anyway
when did i ever let my lack of knowledge
do anything
real and true real and motherfucking true
ah right don't do that
eh even shading stop i'm getting
bullied by this right no why do i keep
messing up look right enough one two
three i'm just drawing downwards now
right there we got her shading and i'll
do a little bit that way and then because
this is like the fold of the toe it
should technically have like shading
right uh surely one of you guys are
foo friends
kopium i like feet actually you know what
i like feet and i'm tired of pretending
i don't i like feet i like giantism i
don't care what anyone says it's weird
it's rooted in this no i don't care i
enjoy it i enjoy what i enjoy
sometimes in life just enjoy what you
want to enjoy you know like it doesn't
have to be cool you don't have to
you don't have to uh you don't follow the
public uh i don't know why we're judging
foot fish when it's like literally one
of the biggest common fetishes ever like
seriously no like for real for real
actually look up look up it's in the
dictionary so it's gullible no seriously
gullibles in the dictionary so we're in
the dictionary wait if i did that can i
just all right all right all right all
right all right oh my god look at that
it's coming at the page she's gonna step
on you reef like run okay now we need to
like shade her her arson shit okay let's
shade
we're doing it sorry but the shading is
helping it's like bringing it's making a
3d
how it's coming it's becoming 3d i don't
care why no one says it's becoming 3d
her boobs are popping out the screen
right now right her arm
yes would have shading on it uh huh uh
huh oh yeah mm-hmm all right all right
let's go let's go uh huh right that's
normal i would have sure she's in there
her ears would cast a slight shade
nothing major but her ears do cast the
shade are you squid me right now i don't
know are you squid me you're pronouncing
gullible wrong gullible no i'm no
show up your arson okay um thank you the
booty lord i'm saying gullible right
they were like why are you saying it
penalized and i'm like because that's how
you do it apparently it's penalized
in the united states of america
we've been penalized by the system right
spell penis right now and then spell
penalized and then tell me what the
difference is okay tell me what the
difference is because you can it's
literally just penalized penis fantasize
okay her boobs would cast a shadow on her
arm as well okay hold on i need to get
rid of this line that shouldn't be there
there we go that's right open up that tit
revenue
it's revenue what a unique what a unique
vocabulary you possess thank you
thank you thank you yes yes why yes of
course okay shading they'd probably be
shading on oh sorry the prop no they'd
probably be shading here i don't mind if
i take some pixels out but if i start
taking out like the black outline of the
pixel that's when it's like becoming a
problem because you're taking away the
masterpiece it's okay the british way is
the only correct way thank you okay so
let's see what the skin looks like now
good good good we've got a little shade
different areas and stuff um her arse cheek
definitely let's zoom in real quick let's
zoom in our hair would cast a shadow
over her face and stuff
definitely like here oh my god no right
no see when i start getting inaccurate
and the pixels start ruining my masterpiece
that's it that's when i'm leaving remember
that time i won twice and go
remember that time i add a member
remember that time my ancestors heard my
plea don't make a fool did you add her
tattoo no thank you for reminding me
though
uh i guess the shadow would only tiny
tiny tiny up here there wouldn't be much
of a shadow cast at that point i don't
think you do maybe here shadow cast
because of this bit of hair yeah i can see
that and then it would kind of stop once
it gets really close to her face it
would pretty much look let's fix this
little bit yeah good
um right her markings are light purple on
her nails oh my god that's matt azura
that's my daughter right there i love you
i love you and you're gonna make everyone
so happy and so proud of you and you don't
know it yet you're just a little boy either
there we go that's my daughter and she
also has a mark on her thigh but you
wouldn't see it from this angle right
and then next we're gonna we're gonna
do ass shading how just how much shade
does this ass need okay so maybe it would
be like a line to really show how
down with the thickness she is and then
so i'm like trying to pretend i know how
light sourcing works i don't what if you
like a weird circle
i don't know maybe it would actually be like a you like
like because it obviously is underneath and we are ignoring the laws of gravity
and physics i don't know what one
shading is like what law is but since we're okay
okay let's i think this wouldn't be
entirely inaccurate it's a little like she
shot herself no no um yeah that's kind of how
shadows work that's kind of how shadows
work hold on let's see it looks yeah and
then it would maybe be a little bit here
hmm look i'm not hating it i don't care
when i was this i ain't hating i'm i'm here for a good time
if you don't look at the face it's actually not that bad
okay and then this would just kind of have a little
slithering section take it there do there and then just go around
oh wait no i can just fill it in once i've closed it hey there we go boom
see uh i do see a bit of that a little bit of this a little bit of that
how would you like some of this on your that yeah right next we are going to
still shade her skin oh my god artists no wonder you guys charge so much this
takes fucking forever this is a joke right her fingers are on top of the
her little hip here so they would go like this
oh my god i'm not putting nail polish on
so this is to show like yeah it's not it's not perfect but it doesn't have to
be yeah you don't have to judge yourself so harshly darling
and then her thumb is behind the thigh that's why you only see one of them
we'll just kind of pop that in there clear up a bit
the face still needs a nose nah you don't do a nose for anime
what you want this
like anime noses are like that and nothing more
um oh god i forgot her jewellery headband
look look she'll forgive me okay she'll forgive me right let's show that this
hair is behind so the hair that's behind kind of gets a shadow cast on it here
i don't know how shadows work on hair on anime here
i don't know how it works on anime here this is something out of my pay grade
um i don't know how it works on here maybe we just skip the hair part
if maybe we just focus on the face shadow how about that that's important but right
if only i had an artist to actually do this
um
but for certain what is the face that is on i should know you know what
how did they didn't work in here i don't know i'm just gonna throw it around the place where
i think it belongs i'm gonna get belong over here nope i might do this little thing over here why not
not yeah why not why not and then like it would have a big bit back here
that seems a bit right
that seems a bit right oh god it's stunning
uh sure it should have a little bit over here why not
oh i'm like completely destroying the outline
um
there you go and then a shadow would be cast here because of the hair and the lake source
not so much around these parts okay and then what next
i mean if we're gonna get really technical bing and boom oh nope bing and boom right
next shade the purple yes yes i shade the purple and then i think we're done
i have boobalicious my money
i wish i could help but my skill points are negative honestly need to
i'm just letting the wheel be taken i'm just gonna do like a big swoop up her foot
and do that and see what happens
all right so that kind of gives like the back of the heels like further away maybe if
maybe if i did that no that doesn't look right that's okay that's okay that's okay let's try again
try again right her suit definitely her big fucking honkers absolutely her absolutely just
thriving her honkers are casting a shadow and then we boop all right uh-huh and then her juicy
would also cast a shadow uh-huh uh-huh and then because of the
a rotundness the rotundness of her milkers it would offer a you type shadow over on this side
which would also be extended on the gold as well so we're gonna quickly just do that on the gold
we'll offer the same you turn on the gold
uh-huh and then a little kind of uh-huh uh-huh oh come on oh come on just higher menu
maybe a little bit of cheeky boob on this but
quite really feeling on the ears all right all right mm-hmm okay now what
did we call it is it done
did we do it
please step on me mommy that's it i think maybe question mark i think we did it i'm not gonna
lie i think we uh that took me an hour to do holy shit no wonder ours cost so much give the
knee a little shade oh okay okay okay a little bit shade a little bit tea right let's grab the
purple let's give this knee some definition even if it's just this because i don't know how knees
work i'm just i'm just here okay i'm gonna sneeze okay i'm good all right i oh i forgot the right
at least let me do the jewels on her head actually her jewels her jewels were like so freaking hard
to get concert we got so much art back that was wrong but it was because of me that was the problem
i'm just gonna manually do it like this i'm just gonna manually do it like this i know i know
it's bad i know and i've missed all the like the her headband and stuff i'm so sorry
oh my god genius i think i maybe need to give her horn some rungs as well
i just need it to be a bit later and then we can kind of yeah
okay all right all right oh we're i don't i don't want to say it but
look all i'm saying you can hire me you can hire me okay if we're gonna put the blue
blue jewels there we might as well put them on the end of her just a little bit oh fuck her necklace
just when you think you're free okay and then her necklace is literally diamond diamond octagon
square that's fine i'll do octagon
okay and then the chain would be put together like maybe slightly lighter than that i was like
yes as i said what i'll do i'm gonna end stream i'm gonna message her and see
she's got time to for me to very quickly bring her on to be like surprise i drew this with the
reeflings this is from me and the reeflings um and she'll be like oh my god that's the
no she won't she'll be very thankful as her is truly lovely i'll hire you but no for
when are you open up commissions i'll be your first customer honestly oh yeah
it just looks like we got the team version of azura but i like it though like i put my love
into it and i like it i like how one boob is like far bigger than the other as well really
really goes for the realism um i like it right if you're satisfied on so we started with this as
the reference right and we somehow so that was please step on me mommy and that was the original
reference it's not bad it's not could be worse it's not bad it's trying smoothly
oh her necklace is held together by purple i don't even realize that hold on analyze
analyze enhance i'm in
oh no i think it's a bit darker than that how about that oh maybe it's her horn color
her neck looks like this
okay let's hold on enhance again i can hardly see the color yellow it's absolute shite so
there we go that's my baby girl that's my baby girl there she is right
did i just do the headband
i think i should do the headband
right let's just manually do the headband okay so she has diamond
and then she has her symbol because she was a founder of air and then a diamond right
right and she has this golden plated thing golden plated okay
what's bad as you think it is it's okay if your mind complicates things sometimes as long as
you're able to work through it that's the main thing there that looks more like my daughter
there we go there we go there we go there we go maybe a little bit brighter maybe maybe a bit
more of an orange but brighter maybe for for connecting the jewellery
i'm not going to put detail on the chain though because it's such a small thing it
might actually take away but that is my daughter okay let's let's see come on you know that scissors
from my class right what i'm going to do my darling reeflings i understand today was rather short
and maybe not the most popular stream concepts however i'm going to redirect into azura
and if she is available i will pop up for five minutes to show her this artwork if she's not
available and i will i'll still send it to her it's not problem oh no i'm already redirecting
to her oh my god i did it earlier i'm so fucked such a piehead mommy leave it do you want me to
do a wee bit of marshmallow before we send it on i'll do a bit of marshmallow i can do a bit
marshmallow if you want don't read this on stream i don't look at full i don't look at links like
that sorry i don't look at links like that has to be cat but mommy i have a weird request maybe
don't read this part on stream
um
i can't talk until i can talk my darling reefling but yes you wouldn't do it on the do
i always love me mallows mommy forgive me i fell into temptation this normally isn't a problem
but it happened while you were collabing today i'm sorry you were so cute i had to thank you
inked while i was playing golf it reefling how much of a broken you you inked while i was playing
golf it how oh the way that strongy putted the ball into the hole oh reefling
i love when she says don't read this on stream and goes i'm just curious hello oh i can't read it
you and kohai have the same model by the same artist but have the same default expressions but
mine still has your smile and mercies as with a a c oh that's really cute hold on you fart
that fart was so big i had to frog blink with fuck
he dreamed to be the whole in one
do you mean it don't underestimate our time and we want to ink any time of day
oh i'm so sorry my patreon right i think you're gonna get two patreon uploads in a row for me
everyone else's patrons are timed holy crap it's farten season
oh my god if you just heard the noise that came out of me
oh my god bro i started lifting off in my chair what the fuck is going on is that
because i've had two cups of tea instead of one i'm a wee bit lactose intolerant but oh my god
that would not stop ah that was not stopping what the fuck mns18 thank you for the tattoo
reminder as well i guess we're recording your farts holy frick strawberry to me well like it
doesn't come out right away and then it just kept going i wouldn't stop mommy don't read this on stream
i love you why would i not say i love you on stream or why would i not read it
happy birthday to zero hell yeah happy birthday to zero i'm gonna go watch her my my darling baby
i'm gonna go watch her and see how she's doing i think she's doing what i mean thank god she
didn't have the emmy incident with that one emmy clipped it she like sent it she's like here's the
i always say to the girls i'm like if you ever fart on stream please send me it i must sound like
some fucking barat bro to them but i'm like it always gets like interaction and stuff i'm like
hi mommy you can read this out loud i love you i love you terry Flynn did you enjoy the
gulfic collab in drona zero yeah she looks cursed as fuck no i'm not gonna apologize
wait for the day that i accidentally don't mute bro honestly you're gonna get in trouble you're
gonna be shocked at the noises can you bark for me i wish i could bark but i don't i'm like a boop
boop boop boop like that's that kind of bark it like i can't do the
like that's not i don't know like i can't imagine like you know ding dong and myself and going
like i'm no a burfer i'm a boof you know
as a great anon once said i have been groomed by mommy
me i'm glad i could groom me uh oh wait
i'm sorry these are the inside thoughts slipping out i'm just having a good time i'm sorry
i'm sorry i don't know why i said that point blank i'm sorry i'm sorry okay i don't know why i
said that hi stroney i need you to step on me now after the stream also i need that reference
fall for reason oh at least let me take an honest if you want me to do a step on you
fall at least let me take a real one instead of that because like i put that together right
before i went to sleep because i knew i had to prepare for it for after the collab
why it's okay to say out loud it's consensual don't be sorry we enjoy being groomed oh you're so
mature for your age riefling um hi mommy it's me riefling hello riefling it's a bia stroney
i forgot the soup oh my god i made this soup it's fucking delicious i'm gonna still take that
photo by the way but oh my god the soup is fucking delicious i'm so proud of myself the only
thing is i didn't do enough water because it ended up getting boiled down to like pure concentrated
flavor which i don't mind but i think i only have like two servants max oh my god the soup is delicious
i'm so proud of myself i kid you not if the girls come for an offline collab i am fucking i am
fucking cooking in that kitchen i will feed my daughters i am so proud of that chicken soup i
couldn't believe it i roasted the veggies and i like strained it and all that and i had to add
extra water i think what i did by is technically bouillon it came out amazing i'm like so proud of
myself so so proud of myself i made a fucking mess so that's the only thing um i've still not cleaned
it up i'm sorry it's an absolute mess in my kitchen right now so a riparoni pepperoni but
yes i will take that photo i promise i will um i just had a lot to prepare and tomorrow i'm like
99% sure i need to prepare a hypnosis script uh i need to prepare for that and i'm like uh
uh you know but uh yeah i'm just so happy what color today if applicable same as usual
reefland same as usual there ain't none on me oh the traditional wayfork incoming yeah bouillon
these nuts also understandable the only reason i hate kicking is the mess literally i'm like i just
kind of yours uh i will say one thing about ordering takeaway order no no stop naughty
the one thing about paying for the exchange of a takeaway is that you can just shove it in the bin
once you're done like there's need cleanup other than a fork or if they provide you a fork then
literally you don't even have to do that part um but what i'm gonna do next time i get a chicken
because i think that'll be my dinner for the next two nights i'm gonna get a chicken but i'm gonna
like purposefully put in four liters because my soup pot has like a litre gauge i put in two liters
um but i'm gonna do four liters this time um and like the vegetables the lentils i had red split
p lentils or whatever they're called you'll do great tomorrow mama oh thank you crazy jessie
i hope you're ready to forget your name hehehe don't forget your name um amazing chefs and
doesn't work for us given to your earworms resistance is futile i can't it's so bad
um but yeah i literally came it's so good i'm so proud of myself so i think i'm gonna try and make
maybe minestrone soup i think it's got bacon in it bacon and pasta and tomato base soup and i'm
like that sounds delicious as well but i might give the chicken soup a few goes until i'm like
really satisfied with it like i didn't boil the potatoes i roasted them in the oven and then
every all the roasted veg went in with the soup and like uh boiled and then brought to a boil and
then simmered for like another hour and like oh my god all the flavors were like umami i fucking
love carrot and soup as well what the fuck was that noise um is that lit my copyright free
is that it did he just moan
i'm listening to emotional and cam zelda music to relax so it all heard was
uh what
mommy is niki like a dog i'm not niki i have like a pool over hoody thing i'll show it i'll show
link get a little long to get a little freaky that was definitely a linksin did you leave popcorn
in the back yeah i didn't i behave
you
relaxing in its crashing sense
what's going on i thought this was supposed to be cammy mummy if i may be so forward no color
can we see a picture wait until the picture how about that i love you so much please keep being
you you're so you're so pure hearted and a blessing to the world stop it reflin you're a blessing to me
i must i'm allowed to be selfish and say that you're a blessing to me not to the world because
you're for me you're mine and hopefully i'm allowed to say that hi mommy what are your thoughts on
gunning and gunners i want to join you that's my thoughts are i want to be i want to get like you
boy but i'm broken the peril is broken at the moment relaxing crashing into your house was it real
i really really like that you just walk about niki but if there was well there would be a lot
of free use going on oh yeah you think i would take it or do you think i would get bright make
your work for it i think you could handle me that's cute hi strony i want to try some of your
soup but not the chicken one let me love me some strony soup
hey hi strony i deeply honestly partially thoroughly completely want to hear that
strony werewolf chases you down surely it can go on twitter do you want it for halloween
i'll make it i'll make an exception and i'll put it on i'll make an exception and i'll
our word you want halloween yeah you halloween
yeah okay i mean i'll write it i'll be fucking i'll be telling you like take my note and say i
don't give a fuck oh wait do you want me to be do you want me to be female or do you want me to be
a werewolf female wink wink and she wonders why the reeflings ink while she's streaming
strony i think you would be the one to take it from i am the one pull it okay
we won't oh no we'll do i don't know if we can pull it right now that's right take my wear pups
plop plop plop plop plop plop we'll pull it in halloween how about that yeah you're halloween
hey when we write the script we'll pull it would strony soup be with waffles becomes
true powerful i love true powerful your small barks are so cute yeah you like my yappy bark
mommy i dare you to read this on stream love you love you yeah i love you very fun
but what if we were the werewolves i'd be game over oh no there's a werewolf chasing me in the
woods oh no i've tripped and fallen over this branch i sure hope my my the noises i make
aren't too loud for you to hear me mr werewolf refling
basically is how i would hold on you have edged me with your fart denial for two long women i
can't handle it i never considered farts as a fetish you've broken me i'm not even touted
i've actually not even touted how can i have given you something that i'm not provided
well mate my tentacle just went up with what you said about being naky and brattie around
the house i will go feral and go full cnc on you oh refling that's bad
do it
i'm gonna try and change my work schedule so i get to watch every night i'm addicted to your company
whoa that's fucking dedication wait what are you gonna go night shift so you can watch us
that's fucking dedication holy shit real and true
feel command and conquer oh there's pokemon diamond and peril songs no copyright
don't need to be so creepy what the fuck right back to legend aselda
i'm really creepy for the reason
all right my darling all right my sore lin i am going to try and sneak onto aser's stream
if possible if that's okay with you guys bad refling i'm not gonna stop you but bad boy
basically um if you guys are okay i'm gonna redirect you into aser i'm gonna then dm aser
if she's okay with me being on because i've got a photo for her basically and i'll just say that
me and the reflin came up with it together
and then she'll be like damn you drew that and i'm like fuck yeah i drew that with crayons and a
piece of paper but i'll see you over in a zero stream deal and then tomorrow i'll hypnotize
you forget your name please remember tomorrow i am up two hours uh than my normal stream time so
i can redirect into ac because per ac never gets a chance to be redirected into so we're gonna do
a birthday raid okay now go love azura nya go go kiss your mommy no
right i'll see you in a zero stream okay give it give me like five minutes because any like
message or be like hey can i come in and all that and she may be distracted right now okay
so give her a minute damn girl you draw like this basically is what her reaction gonna be
okay thank you so so much reflings i'm sorry it's so short um today and tomorrow is short but
i assure you be getting to the big things very soon okay love you reflin i'll see you tomorrow
okay darlin okay rsc in azura stream okay get redirected plop plop plop i'll call me and
paste darlin kiss what get get redirected plop plop plop plop plop plop plop plop plop plop plop
okay you've been redirected love you see you tomorrow or see you in five